[Musik]
Deutschland im krisenmodus immer mehr
geflüchtete kommen über die Grenzen wir
sind voll wir können nicht mehr
volle Turnhallen volle Zelte
verantwortliche im Dauerstress
das ist 2015 Impotenz das muss man ganz
klar sagen
für manche sind es einfach zu viele
wir können unmöglich alle aufnehmen die
hierher kommen wollen
[Musik]
wohin mit den vielen Menschen immer mehr
Städte und Kommunen schlagen Alarm
[Musik]
Dresden Hauptbahnhof hier kommen täglich
Flüchtlinge an die Bundespolizei ist
deshalb im Dauereinsatz gerade wird
dieser Zug aus Prag überprüft guten Tag
die Bundespolizei
viele Männer aber auch Familien und
alleinreisende Kinder sind dabei
Minderjährige die alleine losgeschickt
werden sei es aus Syrien oder aus
anderen Ländern und die schlagen sich
dann über Wochen über Monate teilweise
über die Balkanroute wie wir es jetzt
aktuell haben bis nach Deutschland durch
dann nimmt einen das schon mit
am Hauptbahnhof in Dresden kontrollieren
die Beamten aber auch Reisebusse mit
denen in den vergangenen Monaten immer
wieder Flüchtlinge über die
deutsch-tschechische Grenze kommen
[Musik]
ist okay dieser Mann ist Ihnen
aufgefallen er muss zur weiteren
Überprüfung mitkommen
hier ist der der Bereich des Empfangs wo
die Person quasi abgegeben werden es
wird alles registriert es wird auch sage
ich mal grob abgetastet Handys werden
zunächst in Verwahrung genommen
bestimmte Unterlagen Ausweise im Sommer
2022 ist die Zahl der Migranten hier
widersprunghaft angestiegen im Juli
hatten wir knapp 600 Personen die dann
wieder über die Balkanroute gekommen
sind das war dann tatsächlich so dass
ich die Zahlen dann im August mehr als
verdoppelt hat und der September war
dann der absolute Höchststand mit ähm ja
knapp also über zweieinhalb Tausend
Personen die unabhängig eingereist sind
nachdem die Flüchtlinge überprüft sind
werden sie weiter verteilt in die
ankunftszentren
Heidelberg in Baden-Württemberg
hier registrieren Sie den
Flüchtlingsansturm als erste auf der
Fläche einer ehemaligen US-Kaserne hat
das Land ein ankunftszentrum errichtet
täglich kommen hier bis zu 200 Menschen
an
in diesem Bus sind heute besonders viele
Familien die geflüchteten haben teils
eine lange Reise hinter sich kommen oft
vom anderen Ende der Welt
keine Pässe keine Seltenheit wer sie
sind woher sie kommen das werden die
Mitarbeiter später genau überprüfen
während die Neuankömmlinge warten ist
Markus Rothfuß der Leiter des
ankunftszentrums auf dem Weg in die
registrierungshalle
also Moment ist es insbesondere Syrien
Iran ein bisschen Irak Afghanistan
Türkei wir sind definitiv voll wir
können bis 3.500 belegen müssen aber
immer Plätze vorhalten damit wir wissen
wir haben für jeden der zu uns kommt
auch ein Bett
ein Ansturm auf den Sie vorbereitet
waren der aber das Personal langsam an
die Grenzen der Belastung bringt die
meisten fliehen vor Krieg und Verfolgung
einige auch aus Angst vor einem Einsatz
für Putins Russland
ich bin im September vor der Einberufung
geflohen für junge Männer ist es sehr
gefährlich in unserem Land wegen des
Ukraine Kriegs wollen Sie viele
einberufen aber wir sind gegen den Krieg
wir wollen nicht kämpfen also sind wir
geflogen
es kommen aber auch wieder mehr Menschen
über das Mittelmeer und die westlichen
Balkanstaaten wie diese Familie aus der
türkei-station erfassen wir halt die
Daten der seelsuchenden und nehmen ihnen
Halt Fingerabdrücke ab und es wird auch
gleich geklärt ob die Asylsuchenden
beispielsweise schon früher in
Deutschland waren dann nehmen wir ein
Foto und stellen halt den äh sie
Suchenden einen
ankunftsnachweis der sieht dann so aus
ein Dokument das auch diese 18-Jährige
haben möchte er kommt aus Afghanistan
und erzählt von seiner Flucht
nee ich bin über den Iran die Türkei
Griechenland geflogen danach weiß ich
nicht mehr durch welche Länder ich noch
gekommen bin
ein Jahr und zwei Monate später war ich
hier mein Vater hat gesagt geh in dieses
Land hier du kannst hier in Afghanistan
nicht bleiben du hast hier keine Zukunft
Deutschland als Land der großen
Hoffnungen für viele die letzte Hoffnung
so ist nicht auf 150 Personen haben wir
hier jeden Tag und wir versuchen halt so
viel wie möglich zu registrieren wir
sind alle am Limit
Warteschlangen auch vor der
Krankenstation im 24-Stunden-Betrieb
werden die Neuankömmlinge hier
medizinisch versorgt viele sind von
ihrer Flucht erschöpft und
gesundheitlich angeschlagen sowie dieser
junge Mann er war wochenlang von Afrika
nach Europa unterwegs und hatte nur
wenig oder schlechtes Essen
genau
das ist häufig ja gerade mit dem Fluch
Kontext ist es sehr häufig dass wir da
ähm
was geben müssen und
manchmal auch umfangreiche Diagnostik
machen müssen aber es ist häufig ja
viele verschiedene Fluchtrouten bedeuten
auch viele verschiedene Krankheitsbilder
einige kommen mit Hautverletzungen oder
Wunden nach langen Fußmärschen andere
haben schwere Tumorerkrankungen die
sofort behandelt werden müssen viel
Arbeit für das medizinische Personal
die letzten paar Wochen haben wir
tatsächlich
massive
zugangszahlen und auch damit
einhergehend erhöht erhöhte
konsultationszahlen die wirklich auch
die Ambulanz an den Rande dass das der
Leistungsfähigkeit bringt also wenn noch
mehr geflüchtete kommen können wenn das
irgendwann nicht mehr stimmen
die meisten Flüchtlinge bleiben nur
wenige Tage in Heidelberg dann werden
sie im Land weiter verteilt
wir funktionieren wie eine Drehscheibe
so muss man sich das vorstellen die
Menschen kommen an und die werden dann
nach 10 Tagen auch wieder komplett
ausgetauscht und dadurch verlagern wir
die Belastung eigentlich auf die Stadt
und Landkreisen und die müssen am Ende
die Last und vor allem die Kosten für
die Unterbringung der Flüchtlinge
stemmen auf die Anzahl der zugewiesenen
Menschen und auf die Dauer ihrer
Unterbringung haben sie keinerlei
Einfluss für viele Gemeinden ein
Kraftakt
2022 kamen 1,26 Millionen Flüchtlinge
nach Deutschland zum Vergleich in der
sogenannten flüchtlingskrise 2015 waren
es nur 890.000 Menschen
für die meisten Deutschen ist die
Aufnahme von Schutzsuchenden ein Akt der
Menschlichkeit aber es wächst auch der
Zweifel
wir können unmöglich alle aufnehmen die
hierher kommen wollen nicht es gibt so
viele Menschen in der Welt die die in
elenden Verhältnissen leben dass es
keine Lösung sein kann alle die kommen
wollen nach Europa aufzuzwingen
hilft ich meine die haben da extreme
Probleme auch mit der Stromversorgung
und mit dem Wasser man hört ja auch
immer dass die Menschen
leiden und ich finde es gut wenn wir
hier im Platz haben und den Menschen
helfen ob man die alle integrieren
können ist eine andere Sache aber
ich denke so langsam so eine große Not
herrscht sind wir schon irgendwo
verpflichtet
Landkreis Bergstraße in Hessen
hier ist der Sozialdezernent Matthias
schimpft täglich im Einsatz er ist
zuständig für die Unterbringung der
geflüchteten und versucht den
Flüchtlingsansturm irgendwie zu
bewältigen
also wir kriegen ja pro Woche im
Augenblick im Durchschnitt kann man
sagen 85 Flüchtlinge mal ein bisschen
mehr mal ein bisschen weniger das heißt
bis jahresendes ins 891 und das ist von
herausfordernder steht man auch unter
Druck also wir müssen es schaffen wir
haben gar keine andere Wahl
weil was soll ich mit den Menschen hin
viele Unterkünfte in seinem Landkreis
sind schon voll belegt deshalb sucht der
54-Jährige mit Hochdruck nach neuen
Gebäuden die er als
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte nutzen kann doch
die sind Mangelware denn hier im Kreis
gibt es kaum noch Immobilien die sich
dafür eignen
das ist ein organisatorischer Druck die
Situation ist ist schlicht und
ergreifend so anders als 2015 das auf
dem Markt faktisch keine Flächen mehr zu
akquirieren sind
der 5000 seelenort Lindenfels hier wird
dieses ehemalige Krankenhaus als
Flüchtlingsunterkunft genutzt
330 ukrainische geflüchtete wohnen
bereits hier
eigentlich ist das Gebäude ausgelastet
aber Matthias Schimpf muss weitere
Menschen unterbringen sucht hier nach
Möglichkeiten der Bürgermeister ist
skeptisch wir haben kein Objekt mehr wir
können niemand mehr unterbringen also
die nächsten 20 Flüchtlinge die jetzt
nicht hierher kommen müssen in
Turnhallen das muss man sich
vergegenwärtigen und es sorgt dann
natürlich für viel Kritik weil die
Schule keinen Sport und die Vereine
keinen Sport machen können
diese schlechte Stimmung bei den Bürgern
spürt Bürgermeister Helbig als erster er
sieht seinen Ort an der Belastungsgrenze
Matthias schim versucht auszuloten wo es
vielleicht doch noch
Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten geben könnte
wir können uns eigentlich keine weiteren
Flüchtlinge leisten wir müssen sie ja
auch irgendwie ernähren finanzieren
unterbringen aber wir haben keine
Kapazität mehr
doch Sozialdezernent Schimpf hat die
Erfahrung gemacht dass meistens doch
noch etwas geht so hat er vor ein paar
Wochen diese provisorische Klasse
eingerichtet in der jetzt ukrainische
Kinder unterrichtet werden
denn auch die Schulen sind voll und
können nicht mehr alle Flüchtlingskinder
aufnehmen
die tagsüber vormittags unterrichtet
werden und ja wir sind froh darüber dass
wir sowas überhaupt anbieten können
eine provisorische mini-klasse in der
die Kinder zumindest einen geregelten
Tagesablauf haben und auch Deutschland
können
in diese Klasse habe ich nur sechs
Kinder ich habe noch andere Klasse und
ich unterrichten deutsch
Matthias Schimpf und Jens fahldiek vom
Roten Kreuz schauen sich im Gebäude
weiter nach räumen um die sie eventuell
zu Unterbringung weiterer Flüchtlinge
nutzen können
alle ehemaligen Patientenzimmer sind
bereits voll
die meisten wohnen hier schon seit
Monaten und versorgen sich selbst
auf ihrem Rundgang finden die beiden
einen leeren Aufenthaltsraum sollte es
eng werden das noch mal eine Alternative
wo wir sagen und machen hier noch mal
vier bis fünf Betten rein
im dritten Stock wird heute ein Raum
frei
das ukrainische Ehepaar packt gerade
zusammen während ihre drei Kinder in der
Schule sind mehrere Monate haben sie
hier gewohnt
wir ziehen nach Bensheim in eine eigene
Wohnung die Hausbesitzerin ist
wundervoll sie ist eine deutsche dabei
hat uns das Rote Kreuz sehr geholfen
hilft uns wirklich bei allem zum
Beispiel bei Fragen zur Versicherung und
bei Fragen zur Wohnung
ihr Auszug bedeutet Platz für fünf neue
Flüchtlinge immerhin
Landkreis Greiz in Ostthüringen auch
hier ist es für eine Flüchtlingsfamilie
ein guter Tag es ist 8 Uhr morgens und
Familie Ivanovic ist unterwegs
die dreiköpfige Familie aus der Ukraine
hat auch in einer Flüchtlingsunterkunft
gelebt sie beziehen heute eine der
letzten freien Wohnungen die es im
Landkreis Greiz noch gab
alles was man braucht ist da eine
Waschmaschine
alles ist gut und ein großer Kühlschrank
vielen Dank
alles ist vorhanden alles funktioniert
der Herd einfach alles
hier in Deutschland gefällt es uns hier
gibt es keinen Krieg hier ist es gut
hier hilft man uns alles dank der
Menschen die Menschen hier sind wirklich
sehr gut
sie hat die Wohnung organisiert
Landrätin Martina schweinsburg aber
eigentlich ist die Belastungsgrenze
erreicht ich denke mal man sollte sich
hier der Realität stellen wir sind
irgendwann voll wir sind voll wir können
nicht mehr
denn alle Unterkünfte sind belegt im
vergangenen Jahr kamen in Greiz rund
1.600 Flüchtlinge an mehr als doppelt so
viele wie bei der ersten
flüchtlingskrise die im Sommer
aufgestellten Armee zählte sind jetzt im
Winter nicht zu gebrauchen
diese Zelte sind jetzt natürlich leer
wir haben diese Zelte im Sommer
angeschafft wo wir nicht mehr wussten
wohin und auch keine Wohnungen haben das
sind
armeemannschaftszelte für insgesamt also
72 Personen es ist im Moment nicht
zumutbar hier Frauen und Kinder und
Familien unterzubringen wir bemühen uns
jetzt auch noch etwas mehr zu
akquirieren eine Wohnung Raum aber
wir sind am Limit auch einige Bürger
glauben dass bei der Aufnahme der
Flüchtlinge ein Limit erreicht ist ich
habe nichts dagegen wenn Flüchtlinge
kommt die sich integrieren und die
Arbeit sich Suchen
habe ich nicht dagegen aber es gibt eben
auch viele die wirklich nur drauf aus
sind unser Land da abzuschöpfen und die
Politik tut das akzeptieren und das
finde ich nicht in Ordnung die Meinungen
kann ich gar nicht vertreten weil ich
finde ich denke keine von den Personen
kann sich überhaupt einzeln in die Rolle
hineinversetzen wie es wirklich ist in
einem Land gerade zu sein wo Krieg
herrscht wenn wir in so einer
Kriegssituation dann würde ich mir auch
wünschen wollen dass die Menschen in
allen anderen mir auch so
gegenübertreten und das ermöglichen man
denken nur gut wenn junge Männer
in der Woche Vormittag hier irgendwo
sitzen dann sagt man eigentlich arbeiten
warum arbeiten die nicht Kritik die
Martina schweinsburg häufig hört für sie
gab es bisher zu wenig Reformen man
sollte
Integrationsprogramme machen man sollte
Deutschkurse anbieten nicht wie bei uns
reguläre Deutschkurse erst im September
23 wieder zu belegen das darf doch wohl
nicht wahr sein wir können es ist
unmenschlich Menschen hierher zu holen
und die im Sozialsystem zu parken
bei den Kommunen das sind die Kosten der
Kommunen die auf sind ohne sich auch nur
im Ansatz um Integration zu bemühen mit
viel Anstrengung hat sie es geschafft
geflüchteten die nicht gut Deutsch
sprechen eine Arbeitsstelle zu
vermitteln wie in diesem Hotel in
Zeulenroda hier arbeiten mittlerweile
sieben ukrainische Flüchtlinge Ukraine
haben im Gegensatz zu Flüchtlingen aus
Drittstaaten einen besonderen Status sie
bekommen ein Aufenthaltsrecht und dürfen
Arbeiten
Arbeitskräfte die im Gastgewerbe
dringend gebraucht werden eine
Win-Win-Situation für beide Seiten
mit der Arbeit funktioniert es gut die
Kollegen sind hilfsbereit und
verständnisvoll und sie haben uns sehr
viel geholfen
auch der 61-Jährige Nikolai aus der
Ukraine arbeitet hier er wird gerade als
Reinigungskraft angelernt er ist
glücklich eine Arbeit zu haben hallo
[Musik]
die Arbeit hilft ihm auch den Krieg in
der Heimat zu verdrängen
[Musik]
ja und macht alles sorgfältig und das
gefällt ihm
Produkte ich arbeite und habe eine
Wohnung
und vielleicht mal dein Auto das wäre
schön
noch fahre ich mit dem Fahrrad
[Musik]
es sind auf jeden Fall immer Menschen es
sind Schicksale es ist wichtig nah in
den Menschen da dran zu sein und es ist
wichtig
das Vertrauen dieser Menschen zu
genießen und das ist eben auch eine
große Verantwortung
in Hessen im Landkreis Bergstraße spürt
auch Sozialdezernent Matthias schimpft
diese Verantwortung jeden Tag er ist
heute zu einer weiteren
Flüchtlingsunterkunft unterwegs einer
Zeltstadt in Bensheim auf diesem
Festplatz stehen seit März 2022 vier
Zelte in denen Flüchtlinge untergebracht
sind
neben dem Personalmangel gibt es täglich
neue Probleme für schimpf- und sein Team
heißt das sie müssen ständig
improvisieren
jedes Zelt hat rund 70 Parzellen jede im
Durchschnitt gerade mal neun
Quadratmeter groß
derzeit wohnen hier knapp 500
Flüchtlinge und täglich werden es mehr
gerade wird ein neuer Lagercontainer
geliefert nebenan ein Duschcontainer ans
Strom und Wassernetz angeschlossen für
hunderte Menschen aus dem Nichts
Infrastruktur schaffen
dass diese Einrichtung hier eigentlich
nur für drei Monate stehen sollte das
war zu Abfederung der Ukraine Krise für
die Menschen die zu uns kommen Sie
schnell unterzubringen und dann
praktisch aus dieser Unterkunft
wegziehen zu lassen
aber die Realität hat uns überholt
seitdem ist die Zeltstadt eine
Dauereinrichtung weil es keine
Alternativen gibt mehr Menschen bedeutet
auch mehr versorgungsaufwand
Lebensmittel Matratzen Waschmaschinen
Bettgestelle alles muss für die
steigende Zahl an Menschen heran
geschafft werden
das nächste Problem steht schon vor der
Tür für den Winter müssen die Zelte
winterfest gemacht werden die Zeit
drängt denn weitere Flüchtlinge sind
angekündigt
das ist immer eigentlich im Grunde
wieder dasselbe was sie machen kriegen
wir ein Zelt kriegen wir vielleicht
Container du hast gesagt wie
Leichtbauhalle Art teuer wie lange
Bauzeit und dann wenn du dann so was
hast dann geht's ja erst los Betten
besorgen eventuell die die Bauzone oder
Stellwände Matratzen kaufen ne auch die
Lagerkapazität die müssen ja Unmengen
von Bettzeug auf vorhalten die Leute die
wir hier donnerstags ankommen kriegen
ihre Registrierung und dann bekommen Sie
Ihr Bettzeug Ihre Matratze ihre
Trinkflasche also jeder hat auch
Personal Trinkflasche dass sie einmal
Grund ausgestattet werden ein
logistischer Drahtseilakt den der
54-Jährige organisieren muss jeden Tag
bemüht er sich Platz für noch mehr
geflüchtete zu schaffen irgendwie
heißt
Feld 2 1 2 1 umgezogen durch die neue
Aufteilung wesentlich mehr Belegung bei
weniger Platz und das was hier zu sehen
ist oder was sie hier siehst wird dann
noch im Laufe des Tages hier zugebaut
und weitere Parzellen ausgebildet alle
müssen enger zusammenrücken Privatsphäre
auf neuen Quadratmetern gibt es kaum
wie eng es ist zeigt uns inner horeaner
die Ukrainerin wohnt mit ihrer
14-jährigen Tochter Anastasia seit drei
Monaten hier
unsere Zelt besteht aus zwei Teile meine
Freundin wohnt mit ihrer Sohn wohnt hier
sie können gut genau
ein Etagenbett ein Stuhl kein Tisch das
war's viele Leute auf engem Raum
bedeutet wo es Konfliktpotenzial ja und
das versuchen wir halt durch diese
einzelnen Parzellen ein bisschen zu
separieren dass wir da einfach Ruhe
reinbekommen das gelingt nicht immer ein
bisschen Ruhe würde sich Matthias
Schimpf auch wünschen doch daran ist
nicht zu denken ständig muss er sich um
die Versorgung der Flüchtlinge kümmern
aber dabei auch die Kosten im Blick
behalten
im Monat 750.000 Euro das ist einmal die
Miete für die Zelte dass der geringste
Teil der größte Teil geht für und
Dienstleistung drauf das ist der
Betreiber dass das Catering und das sind
die Energiekosten
mehr als 16 Millionen Euro kostete den
Landkreis die Versorgung der
geflüchteten allein im vergangenen Jahr
der Bund hat insgesamt 4,5 Milliarden
sogenannte entlastungszahlungen für
Städte und Kommunen für 2022 eingeplant
viel Geld das auch Schimpf hilft für ihn
und sein Team bleibt es dennoch eine
Herkulesaufgabe das ist 2015 Impotenz
das muss man ganz klar sagen es ist eine
Aufgabe die nie endet
denn keiner weiß wie viele noch kommen
werden Matthias Schimpf und sein Team
tun alles damit die Menschen hier gut
versorgt sind
es gab sogar Mitarbeiter die ihr
Privatauto voll geladen haben mit
irgendwelchen Kissen das muss man sich
vorstellen das kommt dann einer mit
seinem Privatauto und hat hunderte von
Kissen in sein Auto gestopft nur damit
dann zur rechten Seite einfach Kissen da
sind
das Leben im Zelt bleibt für die meisten
Flüchtlinge dennoch eine Belastung viele
vor allem Ukrainer sind hin und
hergerissen einige wollen wieder zurück
in ihre Heimat wieder andere wollen hier
einen Neustart schaffen für innere
horeaner und ihre Tochter ist die Lage
in der Heimat noch zu unsicher sie
möchten vorerst in Deutschland bleiben
deshalb lernen die beiden fleißig
Deutsch nein ich zurück nicht
ich weiß nicht was wird morgen wie haben
leben hier ja und wir müssen gehen Leute
im Ukraine ich habe keine Möglichkeit
lernen ich hoffe alles wird gut ich
glaube im Glück im Gott
ich liebe Welt
die Situation für die geflüchteten so
erträglich wie möglich zu machen das
haben sich Schimpf und sein Team zur
Aufgabe gemacht wer das im Echtbetrieb
hier erlebt für die Menschen aus der
Ukraine der kann nicht zur Einschätzung
kommen dass Leute aus Spaß an der Freude
Herr flüchten wie gesagt diese Menschen
hatten ein gutes Leben und das ist von
heute auf morgen auf den Kopf gestellt
worden und wir die sie hier an der Basis
unterbringen haben sehr wohl gesehen was
das für ein Leid ist das macht kein
Mensch der
sozialtourismus betreibt da ging es uns
nackt überleben und einfach darum seine
eigene Haut zu retten
Krefeld in Nordrhein-Westfalen Besuch
bei einer der 1.000 Tafeln in
Deutschland gerade werden gespendete
Lebensmittel angeliefert heute früh sind
alle ehrenamtlichen Helfer im Stress wie
seit Monaten doch ob die Lieferung heute
für alle Bedürftigen reicht weiß keiner
weniger Nahrung auf mehr Menschen
verteilt die Rechnung kann man sich
denken ja aber müssen wir durch geht
nicht anders
Ansturm an Bedürftigen
in 2022 waren es insgesamt zwei
Millionen Tafelkunden ein Anstieg um 50%
im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
eine Entwicklung die Hans-Georg Rehbein
mit Sorge beobachtet sie haben
gewaltigen Zustrom im letzten halben
Jahr sind fast 1000 Menschen dazu
gekommen die Situation ist sehr sehr
bedrohlich wir haben also großen Zustrom
dass wir Angst haben bald nicht mehr
alle Menschen versorgen zu können jetzt
im Moment kommt wirklich alles zusammen
da kommt die flüchtlingskrise da kommen
die Energiepreissteigerung in der kommen
die Preissteigerung unter den
Lebensmitteln und diese Gesamtsituation
wird dazu führen dass auch in den
nächsten Monaten bestimmt noch viele
Menschen zusätzlich zur Tafel kommen
müssen
jede dritte Tafel in Deutschland hat
deshalb einen Aufnahmestopp verhängt
hinzu kommt dass die gespendeten
Lebensmittel immer weniger werden die
Tafel Krefeld hat jetzt erstmals
Lebensmittel zugekauft weil es sonst
nicht reicht die Organisation und ihre
Mitarbeiter kommen an ihre Grenzen
wir hatten vorher schon Flüchtlinge und
die Ukraine sind dazu gekommen und
strengt eigentlich den Rahmen wir sind
Ehrenamtler wir machen alles mit mir
arbeiten mit mehr Zeitdruck und
irgendwann kommt man als Limit wo man
dann wo der eine dann sagt ich kann
jetzt mal nicht kommen ich bin ich bin
fertig
erschöpfte ehrenamtliche auf der einen
Seite auf der anderen Tafelkunden die
Angst haben zu kurz zu kommen
Verteilungskampf ist ein hartes Wort
aber
muss man sagen die Realität sieht so aus
ja
wir schauen natürlich das zu keinem
wirklichen Kampf kommt aber
ja es ist schwierig einfach
um Streit unter ihnen zu verhindern hat
die Tafel ein ausgabesystem entwickelt
mit Uhrzeit und Nummern
das sind 250 Familien damit die nicht
alle gleichzeitig kommen denn das Geld
dann tumulierte vor dem Haus aber auch
innen drin und manchmal gibt es dann
auch sage ich mal schwierige Situationen
um die zu vermeiden haben wir den Leuten
immer einen Plan gemacht wie es nächste
Woche aussieht wann sie dran sind ich
bewundere immer wie sie das schaffen die
Ware die Sie haben so einzuteilen dass
die letzten noch wirklich noch was
bekommen man versucht immer ganz gerecht
zu bleiben aber das ist ein schmaler
geraten
gerechte Verteilung die Mitarbeiter der
Tafel geben sich Mühe aber es bleibt
eine Konkurrenz um das weniger
Angst zu wenig zu bekommen
eine große Rolle wann merkt es auch in
den Gesprächen mit den Menschen das war
schon in der Flüchtlingsbewegung 15 16
der Fall die sehen der kommen viele
viele neue die nehmen ihnen in
Anführungsstrichen die Nahrung weg
13 Uhr der erste Andrang diese junge
Frau ist heute die erste
kommt aus der Ukraine und aus diesem
Grunde nehme ich sie auf
sie bekommt Lebensmittel für sich und
ihre Tochter der Ansturm der Bedürftigen
ist groß die Zahl der Tafelkunden steigt
jeden Tag
unter ihnen sind viele Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine die Hilfe von einer
Dolmetscherin brauchen
oft klappt die Verständigung aber auch
mit Händen und Füßen und zur Not mit dem
Handy
16 Uhr langsam wird die wahre knapp
als erstes wird das Brot streng
eingeteilt denn draußen stehen immer
noch Menschen ich habe
vor kurzem
statt Brot bekommen die letzten heute
mehr Obst dann ist Schluss
es war ein guter Tag für alle Kunden und
Helfer in Krefeld die Mitarbeiter sind
geschafft aber glücklich
Kunden gehabt die alle etwas bekommen
haben die alle hoffentlich zufrieden von
uns gehen werden
ein zehn Stunden-Tag geht für die
Mitarbeiter der Tafel in Krefeld zu Ende
die leeren Kisten werden eingeladen und
sind morgen hoffentlich wieder gefüllt
denn dann werden wieder viele Bedürftige
vor der Tür der Krefelder Tafel stehen
[Musik]